let me start by saying uh congrats on
the movie and i love when people um that
are not
representation matters yeah and i'm very
happy that you are the lead in this
movie and this movie was made thank you
so i have a few curveballs before i get
into the actual making of the movie but
i don't know if you've ever thought
about this but if you could get the
financing to make anything you want what
would you make and why oh man that's a
great question um oh man
a b-boy movie
yeah because it's really expensive and i
want and that's a part of my life and
it's a part of my culture
and i and i mean that as like like the
dancing aspect it was a big part of my
life and i love that culture and
a lot of b-boys are
you know never gotten their their
flowers
and and it's an expensive expensive
event you know just because of the music
alone
so
that would be on my wish list to make
the the sickest b-boy movie ever made
by the way they're finally getting their
flowers because they're gonna go to the
olympics
yeah it's finally an olympic sport if
someone has actually never seen anything
that you've done what is the first thing
you want them watching and why first
thing that i have a
live from seattle
live from seattle because
uh
to me that was my heart my everything
because i wore
every hat
uh
the risk was
extremely high and the reward was zero
because
no one wanted it
and and even though everyone said no and
i mean everyone everyone said no they
didn't want my special
and i didn't care
and my manager and i decided to shoot it
and we used our money
and even up until the day we had all the
cameras inside the venue we get another
phone call saying we don't want it
[Laughter]
and that was netflix that said we don't
want it and uh and i still proceeded to
shoot it
and there was a part in that that
special where i ad-libbed something
and at that moment i knew i had
i knew it was
it was the one
like at that moment when i ad-libbed
this one line in that special where i go
elevate the beat
i've never done that before in my life
and when i said i go i got myself a
winner right here and and literally
that's what happened that changed my
life i can't imagine because putting
your money on the line is like they tell
you do never do this right but what was
it like for you right before you're
stepping out on stage to do the special
how effing nervous are you about oh my
god it's like make or break i was crying
i was crying upstairs in the green room
i was so mad my agent was back there my
manager was back there my son was asleep
and i was 30 years in to stand up and it
was just like how many no's am i gonna
get
like i didn't understand it like i'm
breaking records i was i was selling out
improvs three weeks in a row like six
months in advance and but for some
reason i didn't want to make my special
and then guys that were opening for me
were getting specials
it didn't make any sense you know and ah
like there was a point where i
i wanted to quit
but i had to do it you've performed at
many locations is there one that you
especially get nervous about when you're
about to step on stage because of the
the history of the place or some reason
um the oh i don't get nervous anymore i
don't care where i go up but i get
uh
like excited like overly excited to step
on the stage
um it would be the forum
i've done four in a row now sold out
every single one
and uh
and it there's just something about when
you walk in there's you know that
hallway that you drive in when you drive
in and you have every name that's
performed on that stage and to see my
name painted next to
led zeppelin jackson five james brown
bruno mars journey
and then joe hoy motley crew like what
like what's going on
yeah so pinches i pinch myself every
time i've walked that area that you're
talking about and it's crazy it's nuts
yeah um jumping into the movie um how
long had you been thinking about doing a
movie how long had this been
you know what i mean in development yeah
i i love the art of storytelling and and
that's my favorite style of stand-up and
and my intentions were always to
be able to have you see it when i do it
on stage like in your head you can
already visualize it
you can see that situation in your head
and
so i've always wanted these characters
to come to life so it was always
in me no matter what
and then for easter sunday it was on
tour i was on the tour bus and i
literally came up with this idea of
one day
love
life and chaos
you know what day would that be and i
said easter sunday would be the best way
to tell my story about
my family and my culture what was it
like for you being number one on the
call sheet that was nuts you want to
hear it crazier is how does it feel to
be
called by steven spielberg
that was the craziest part like
you know getting a call from spielberg's
people you know called from amblin and
as i walk into amblin everyone kept
saying you know steven loves your work
stephen can't stop talking about you
stephen watch your special
and you know i tell this joke all the
time i you know but it's the truth i i
really thought it was someone that
worked there i was like you mean stephen
from accounting like who who are you
talking about it can't be mr spielberg
there's no way it's mr spielberg and it
was him
and from that day to where we're at
right now in front of you it's been his
hand involvement inside this project
it's incredible talk a little bit about
listen i and i said at the beginning
and i'm very sincere about this
representation matters and i'm so happy
with the last few years in hollywood i
feel like more voices have been getting
out there with
it just feels that way to me do you feel
that on yours like do you think that
that it's getting better we're moving
we're moving and the doors finally open
you know and with this movie
i'm gonna
do my hardest to keep it wide open you
know because we need more of this
there's a lot of people that live here
that aren't seen and they aren't heard
but yet for some reason you work with
them you hang out with them you know
you're best friends with them but for
some reason on the big screen and on and
on the small small screen they have no
voice you know and they're not heard and
they're ignored
and it's not fair it really isn't
because
you get it you you understand their life
you know who they are
and uh
and that's what this movie is you get a
chance to get inside my family but then
when you leave the movies
when you leave the movie theater you're
gonna be like oh okay his family's just
like my family from when you first
started on the project to what people
are gonna see on screen how much
actually changed along the way in terms
of like the story the script all of it
all of it yeah i mean the original
screen
play to to the final edit i mean final
uh
script uh completely changed 100 changed
and that's that's what we wanted we
wanted it to be
loosely based but also uh
an embellishment of you know my life
and then still represent the culture you
have a son in real life you have a son
in this movie yeah i wanted to know what
does your son think of his character if
you will in the movie my son has not
seen the movie yet oh really no one in
my family has seen the movie they all
want to see it
at the premiere they all want to be
surprised and experienced it
with everybody else so
i can't wait he's gonna love it though
he's gonna love it i love learning about
like the behind the scenes of the making
of films tv whatever what do you think
soon to be fans of the film would be
surprised to learn about the actual
making of it that we shot this during
the the height of covid like literally
that was the only place that was willing
to shoot it which which was vancouver
and
it was extremely mentally and physically
strenuous i hope i'm saying the right
stuff but
yeah it was it was mentally just
strenuous and physically it was
it broke us down because we couldn't be
next to each other so we had to walk and
you know be far away from each other you
know it was like a lot of stuff where
you could have just been hanging out in
the corner in between tanks we had to
like separate ourselves and go to like a
trailer and isolate and you know it
started to wear and tear on you it
started to
break you down
a bit but
uh we still pushed through and it made
it what was it like because um were you
very much like the night before you're
filming a sequence were you in your
brain just thinking about alts and
things that you wanted to do like did
how much pressure did you put on
yourself you know as you were filming i
put all the pressure i i was on the
phone
with my uh my acting coach every night
you know running my lines
figuring out alts
where to ad live um and then you know
presenting those ad-libs to the director
you know i mean and also with my
with my uh whoever i'm acting with
and
and that was that was a lot of fun just
being able to
sharpen that that skill set you know the
stuff with you and tiffany when she
pulls you over is obviously it's very
funny and the the dynamic between the
two of you how much was that scripted
how much was that like you two just in
the moment well we we had the script but
tiffany and i just that's how we talk
so
we're always
that's just us
we literally banter like that
so
that was easy and then of course it's
tiffany you know
like it's it's so easy with her i don't
think she even knew her lines anyway
literally she walked up and it was like
okay and then ran with it and whatever
she did was
the take sure yeah you were basically
filming curb your enthusiasm yeah she
had an outline of what was going on so
good man like she's really that good and
our ad-libs were so good it made the
movie like legit like that was
so cool to see uh
something that we add live make the
trailer i uh laughed a lot at uh jay's
lines about uh i'm losing you i'm in the
canyon um and you know that repeated
joke um who came up with that that's jay
oh that's really yeah jay came up with
all of that jay i mean he's he's a
genius i mean you know jay's work
just as a director alone but then also
the stuff that he's written and shot
um he's incredible and uh
that was uh
a joke that you give most agents right
that was also my manager it was just
like my not my new one my old one where
he would uh act like he was just too
busy right now uh you know let me call
you back
bad signal it's just like no you're just
a bad manager so
yeah that's what that was all about it's
so funny because jay got some
[ __ ] about from his his ages like i
don't do that to you like
see that i like that uh how much
i'm sure you showed the movie to friends
and family maybe some audiences uh what
did you learn from some of those like
test screenings that impacted the
finished film that you know what we
loved the most is that people were just
really uh
really relating like it was so cool like
people got emotional when it was
emotional and i was just like whoa this
is cool like
moms were relating like it didn't matter
what ethnicity they were they were just
like
getting it and understanding and feeling
from my mom in this in this movie so
that was that was the
that was the coolest thing that i i got
from that movie uh from screen uh test
screening i also noticed that
like some of the things that they were
not liking i didn't like and i was like
oof
yeah
so it is an honest uh
opinion like i get it now like i see why
they do the test screenings i've spoken
to a lot of directors and they say it's
it's it's brutal sometimes but it's very
informative yeah very informative so i'm
just so curious so there's a scene in
the church where you take the stage yeah
in the script did it just say he takes
the stage and goes off like how what was
that you know that was that was jay that
was j because like no one really wants
to put a stand-up
comedian character in a movie it's just
like uh
it's been there done that it's like how
do you do it you know what i mean and it
never looks good you know i mean no
matter how you shoot a stand-up
performance it looks like you're
shooting a stand-up performance you know
i mean it looks staged
and uh so jay was the mastermind behind
that he came up with a great idea it's
like hey
you know you and
you and the the priest have a feud and
you know or have some type of tension
and this is his way of getting back at
you getting you on
in front of people
and that's gonna be your stand-up moment
and and we wrote you know some uh we
wrote he wrote and i wrote like this
cool little stand-up sequence
but then
uh i literally just ran with it so i
ad-libbed that that damn thing
which was the scene
that um you had the most fun shooting
and which was the scene that was the
biggest pain in the ass oh the biggest
pain in the ass scene
would have to be uh oh
what was it there's okay the biggest
the the hardest scene for me to shoot is
that what your question was sure was uh
when i cried at the dinner table i shot
it twice i got on the first take
but
emotionally it was the hardest thing and
i don't wish it on any actor and
any actor that's a that's really good at
crying
on on in a scene is
hats off because i pulled from so many
emotions there were trigger words that
that
got me to cry where i was just
emotionally it was hard to like stop you
know what i mean so and then you also
have to read your lines
it was not fun mentally like there there
was a point where i was exhausted and
then all the actors you know hugged me
you know i mean like we were all
involved in it like oh we were all
crying together it was just like that's
a tough scene man that was a really
really tough scene
uh painting a scene would have to be uh
[Music]
god i can't think of any oh uh when it
rained that that was that was a pain
i don't know if it shows but uh it
rained during one of our scenes and it
was killing us
it was killing us you know what i mean
it was when we we saw lou diamond for
the first time at his house it started
raining and we didn't know what to do
because we could not shut down and uh so
we were waiting for the rain to stop and
then we would start we start shooting
and then it would rain again we're like
oh so that was a pain in the ass on that
note i'm just gonna say i'm really happy
you got to make the movie and i hope
it's a huge hit for you guys oh dude
thank you so much